this a seven may look nothing out of the
ordinary but it packs some
state-of-the-art technology Jack as it's
called is one of the world's first
self-driving cars it monitors road
traffic using a range of sensors
calculating for example the distance of
other cars in front behind and to the
sides today test driver Michelle is
taking the concept car for a spin she's
accompanied by two engineers ones in the
passenger seat observing road traffic
the others on the back seat answering
Michelle's questions a section of
Autobahn itself Germany has been
approved for testing what Audi calls
piloted driving here test car jack
drives amid regular road traffic as the
autopilot system becomes available it
flashes up on the car's display and
emits an acoustic signal to keys besides
the steering wheel activate the
autopilot system then the steering wheel
retracts giving the driver extra space
piloted driving also means the car
automatically indicates and overtakes
other cars Michelle doesn't seem
entirely comfortable with this
reluctantly Michelle takes her eyes off
the road and turns around she wants to
know from engineer me close kiss y LD
developed piloted driving he says it's
because driving isn't always fun often
it's just a simple commute from A to B
how he wanted to make such monotonous
driving more enjoyable that's a
tradition he's a student at me out and
talk lots of rooms getting Boyd shell
asked about the difference between drive
assist systems and piloted driving me
Chlo says the drive assist systems
require the drivers constant attention
at any moment the system could switch
back and prompt the driver to take back
control so taking your eyes off the road
and talking to someone on the backseat
is only possible with piloted driving
changes to the vienna convention on road
traffic in 2014 made these developments
possible the convention requires drivers
to have constant control over their
vehicles thanks to the changes
overseeing drive assist systems also
counts as control but for now piloted
driving car jack remains in legal limbo
changes to traffic laws are expected in
the next few years
this Michelle says Audi has focused a
lot on the issue of driver distraction
she wants to know what this means
exactly Niklas explains that for the
past 10 years Audi has been doing all it
could to prevent drivers from getting
distracted when drive assist systems are
activated piloted driving changes
everything now drivers can take their
eyes off the road entirely so keeping
drivers awake becomes crucial now the
distraction posed by drive systems is
welcomed the piloted driving system can
pause entertainment systems at any
moment and prompt drivers to take back
control the business of all funds video
after starting off it
as it happens I'm an acoustic signal has
just prompted Michelle to retake control
a yellow beam indicates that she must
place her hands on the wheel steering
wheel moves back towards her and now
she's back in control
much work still needs to be done to
transform this concept car into a
production model the concept cars
high-end technology won't be available
in ordinary vehicles for a while first
more and more elaborate drive asus
systems will be installed in production
models and only then will piloted
driving become available for ordinary
cars michelle admits she was a little
worried at first but she quickly came to
appreciate the autopilot and says she's
at a very relaxing motorway journey what
does not my [ __ ] yeah